[Music]
foreign
brought to you by the every dollar app
start budgeting for free today Mark is
in Cincinnati hey Mark welcome to the
Ramsay show
hey great to be on here good to have you
how can I help
uh I just had a question about uh
building credit
um I just don't know where to start
um I'm currently a student I'm 23 years
old I am graduating in three months
debt-free
um I don't have any like I said I don't
have any debt I just don't know where to
start with building credit why do you
need to build credit
uh because I'm trying to move out of my
parents house in the next three to six
months that doesn't require credit
um
well from mine I don't know because from
my understanding I know that most
renters want a line of credit or not
true or at least want some kind of
credit history it's not true that's a
lie that your friends tell each other
okay well that's that's why I'm here I'm
here to get some good advice so here's
the thing everybody says that in order
you have to have a credit score in order
to run an apartment and yet we routinely
will pick up the phone and call 10
apartment complexes in any given area
and say hey I'm a student coming out of
college I have zero debt and zero credit
um will you rent to me nine out of ten
of them say yes
and yet all of your friends tell each
other that you have to go get a credit
card to build up your credit because no
one will rent to you but the truth is if
you actually call to an apartment
complexes two of them might not but so
what
the other eight will
some of them may require a slightly
larger deposit which you get back if you
leave the place in good shape and pay
your rent
but you know don't fall for the Trap
Mark the Trap is is that you have to go
build a FICO score and the way you build
a FICO score is you go in debt why do I
do that so that I can borrow money why
do I go into why do I borrow money so I
can build my FICO score why do I build
my FICO score so I can borrow money why
do I borrow money so I can build my FICO
score why do I build my FICO score so I
can borrow money and you it's a dog
chasing its tail and suddenly you're an
American making a hundred thousand
dollars a year and one hundred percent
of your money goes out to some stupid
butt bank because you worshiped at the
altar of the great FICO and that's what
your friends are doing and some of your
their parents are doing but it's not
smart and it's also not factual
yeah well that's what my brother said he
said that a credit score is just an I
love death core well it sounds like he's
been listening to the Ramsey Show
he has he's actually been on your show
before so what's your future look like
you graduate then what
yeah
um
well I graduate uh in December and then
I'm actually going back to school for a
second bachelor's which I only have two
classes left for so by May of the next
year I'll have two bachelors and then
I'll be looking at Masters program what
are you going to be doing for making
money to be able to pay this rent
uh right now I'm working uh full time
and then I'm all I also uh work kind of
part-time in the independent contractor
uh doing group counseling sessions
because that's my that's what I'm going
to school for I'm going to be a
addictions counselor okay so you're
gonna get your Master's so you can get
licensed in the state of Ohio good for
you yeah okay yes so I'm already I'm
already licensed as an addictions
counselor in the state of Ohio I'm going
for a they don't require a master's
counseling
no uh so the way I did it
um you you just need a masters for
higher uh credentials which is that
that's what I'm going for
so why the second bachelors
uh just because it's only two classes
left you I see right you just check it
out it's within reach yeah that makes
more sense okay and so the the I'm just
curious I'm not questioning whether it's
right or not because I just don't know
uh but the second Masters higher
credentials enables you to do what that
you can't do now as a licensed therapist
uh so it's just um so right now I'm
licensed as an addictions counselor uh
but I want to be I want to go into
mental health counseling which requires
a higher level of schooling and that
does require a master that does require
a message that's that's what I want to
go into I mean they won't give you the
license without the Masters is what
you're saying
right So eventually my day going and
found in and own my own uh counseling
kind of
uh organization
holistic yeah good for you mental health
and addictions counseling to
people that are struggling I love that
you're working in the field while you're
going to get the Masters love that
that's a beautiful path
it's gonna it's gonna equip you beyond
what you realize not only are you making
the money to pay for everything yeah but
it's going to equip you very well done
Mark very well done and one other small
practical thing to consider Market may
not be right for you but being single
you're working a lot schooling maybe
getting a roommate for that first
apartment uh will also help solve that
perceived problem as well get in save a
little bit of money you're still renting
you're out on your own but that's an
option and something to think about cuts
the cost down yeah